what do you hope your legacy is
yeah it's going to be javascript i think
no i think you know my legacy has more
to do with
my children and and their children i
think it also has to do with
web standards it has to do with things
like brave the things we did
with firefox when we did um you know i'm
not going to over celebrate but i think
brave is important and we
continue to prove this in a way that
counts for many decades to come but
even firefox whatever it's future
fortune showed you can restart the
browser market this thing you said about
people opting out and routing around you
don't need everybody to do that it's
more like telus
stubborn minorities that do that it's
the lead users eric hipple's lead users
you can be a few percent you can tilt
the market and that
can be done in spite of the incumbents
the moneyed interests not being in favor
of what you're doing so
i think what we do with firefox won't be
forgotten and it needs to be done more
and we're doing it brave and you could
argue that other projects are doing in
some ways blockchain is doing it
the robinhood uh take down uh
the use of uh robin hood by the the wall
street vets kids
yeah similar so yeah that that kind of
spirit endures and i think it
um in some ways it's american right it's
uh it's not hard revolutionary it's not
trying to burn the past and destroy
everything it's more like
we have these certain let's say um
rights we have duties too so there's
some debate about which comes first in
american
jurisprudence and the founding documents
but as long as things are working
we'll we'll we'll be like pragmatic
americans like um
de tocqueville described in his writings
but if if things get too out of whack
for one reason or another
uh too unequal too oligarchic and
abusive
we're gonna start our rights and even a
few of us can do it and even in the
american revolution it was a minority
who fought and put their
you know lives treasure and sacred honor
at stake it was
a bunch of people went to you know upper
canada i think it was called uh
ontario yeah that's the beautiful i mean
that's that is
at the core where your work stands for
is that a few people can have
the power to transform society with just
a few radical ideas with just a little
bit of code
uh yeah change the world gotta do it and
that's empowering and that is the
american way that's why this country is
i believe the greatest country on earth
that's not over
rometz says it too much but uh i think
some special things
uh have already happened in this country
and will continue to happen and that's
and that spirit can continue no matter
you know who comes here
they can they can adopt those folkways
and that spirit
brandon i said i can't tell you how much
i was freaking out how much of an honor
is to talk to you
you're an incredible human being it's
one of my favorite conversations ever
thank you so much for wasting all this
time with me i really appreciate it oh
it seems like a breeze
my pleasure
you